pas combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux
papes il ne faut trop écope monte bien
sûr foudroie des beaux-arts à paris
il nous manque il est vraiment beau
votre sapin
et puis vous savez nous avons après une
hausse en ce moment ah je vous écoute
1 2 3 4
[Musique]
jamais
la forêt
invités
[Musique]
là
avi
m
j'espère que vous ne le changerez pas
toute la nuit
bonsoir
[Musique]
en tout cas moi ça plus je ne dors pas
je veux voir le pardon le père noël ne
vient pas tant que des enfants ne sont
pas couchés
[Applaudissements]
on va voir ce que l'on va voir
qu'est ce que tu veux faire je vois des
coupons plein cela permet autant dans le
tout j'arrive
mais c'est très méchant il va se faire
mal il peut se casser une jambe fois je
vais chercher autre chose
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as dans la main packs
loue aulas pour quoi faire
pour le sommet dans la cheminée la
parole marche au dessus se pique au jeu
j'arrive il sera tellement furieux qui
remportera tout s'est joué ce sera comme
ça
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as encore trouvé dans
la cale
je vais en mettre partout ils se collent
de pied les lamas matin charles est
comme ça les autres petits enfants sont
privés de jouer c'est très gentil sable
où tu en es zumba pata plus je dois pas
parce qu'un stage à pourra bien faire
pour le voir bien monsieur bourbon a
oublié sa canne pas tant que ça va le
banal entre se parlent plus tard la
fille seule ce qui fait on de la classe
à la bazoge arrive ça c'est rigolo je
vais t'aider
[Musique]
maintenant tout le monde au lit
par la gauche que faites vous là mais
j'étais venu chasser mc n est ce que
c'est que cette cloche mais on n'est pas
à pâques noël opaque
c'est toujours une fête note annonçant
la vente en passant la barre ce pas là
ce n'est pas le père noël tu vois bien
que c'est monsieur beauvais menons ce
map armando 12 ans les enfants conviés
3g vous qu'il y ait de pâtes a péché
qu'il ne faut trop d'écho notez bien sur
vos droits
attention isolement
[Musique]